Bonjour and welcome to Brazzaville in the Republic of Congo,...
...a country number 188.
There are many unique things about Brazzaville that I can tell you about...
...such as the green taxis or the impressive bridges,...
...but nothing to me is more special than the sapeurs.
Also known as the Brazzaville dandies,...
...the sapeurs are Congolese men...
...who like to dress themselves in swanky suits, ties and colorful attire.
Why? Nothing more than to gain attention.
The sapeurs pride themselves in dressing uniquely from one another,...
...never wearing the same outfit each day.
They have their own bro code and way of interacting...
...like when greeting each other, they rub the front of their heads together.
It's almost like a cult.
But perhaps the most interesting thing about the sapeurs...
...is that they often come from the slums of Brazzaville...
...but nonetheless managed to get their hands on...
...the most fine tailored suits and accessories.